so many people have a preconceived
notion of what I am capable of just at
first sight when I do my thing and they
see it and they're like woah I love
giving that shock and awe feeling it's
just like so you think I can only do
this but I'm going to show you I can do
so much more my name is Dexter maple and
I am a plus-sized male model and
professional dancer for about eight
years now oh my goodness the journey has
been long it has been hard being a
bigger person there's not as many
opportunities but at the same time
there's so many opportunities that you
would never expect I'm so happy so I've
been able to dance for Jennifer Lopez
for her poppy music video Sara Bareilles
for her brave music video I was actually
able to walk the runway as a plus-size
model for Marco Marco at LA Fashion Week
and that has been an eye-opening
experience for me I was never actually
trained professionally as a dancer I
never expected to be a professional
dancer given my body type being a gay
black man in America is not easy
especially being a big gay black man in
America and it took me a while to really
find that love for myself my true self
whenever we think of bigger men we view
them as something to laugh at and we're
not that we love our bodies as well and
we are sexy too
like I can't say that enough like we are
sexy too
at the end of the day I just want to be
seen as someone who deserves this is
someone who is capable not seen as just
an overweight person not just seen as a
black actor dancer not seen
as whatever that first impression is I
just want to be seen as someone who is
talented enough for this job
you